joining me now is talk to the presenter
sharon osbourne from a home in los
angeles sharon this is such a wretchedly
sad day isn't it
oh my
goodness it's um
heavy heart a really really happy heart
it's you know
you and i millions of people have grown
up with her
and she's always been this tower of
strength and dignity for our country and
you know it's it's
it's heartbreaking i i
i'm heartbroken for our country and i'm
heartbroken for the family
yeah it's easy i mean it's the forget
isn't it this is
there is a huge family there and she's
the head of that family um obviously
they lost prince philip prince philip
last year and now the queen
yeah because royal i think so many
people
missed the point they are a family a
tight-knit family and you know the
grandchildren the grandchildren you know
they have children i mean it it they
must be devastated
completely devastated
sharon when people who aren't british
ask you
about the queen and sort of say well
what's the point of her and
what is she
what was your answer what do you feel
she represented for us as a nation
oh strength
and like i say
why nobody want to come to britain
because of our traditions because of our
royal family everything that comes out
of britain i mean
it's it
it
it's historical and she kept going she
kept that going and that's what makes
britain different to every other country
our tradition so i mean
look look what we went through this year
with with celebrating her i mean it was
magnificent no does that like like the
english do it and you know what sharon i
was i was told actually by somebody very
close to the royal family there were
serious fears in the family that she
wouldn't actually
live long enough for the platinum
jubilee and that she suddenly rallied
quite soon near to the to the
celebration starting she rallied again
and and they believed it was because she
just wanted to go through that and share
that moment with the country and with
the people and then she came out of that
balcony really it was all she did but
what a moment that was when the queen
appeared on buckingham palace balcony i
was
there covering it for fox and i remember
watching this little lady come out 96
years old and the roar
that went up
right the way down the mouth was it was
absolutely spine tingling
it's like this will never happen again
in our country that there will be a
monarch that will reign for so long and
a woman that is
you could never ever say anything
against the queen she never went wrong
with one step and when she when she took
her oath that he would be a servant to
this country she never broke it
sharon i've got a statement here this is
from our new king
uh king charles the death of my beloved
mother her majesty the queen is a moment
of the greatest sadness for me and all
members of my family we mourn profoundly
the passing of a cherished sovereign and
a much-loved mother i know her loss will
be deeply felt throughout the country
the realms and the commonwealth and by
countless people around the world during
this period of mourning and change my
family and i will be comforted and
sustained by our knowledge of the
respect and deep affection in which the
queen was so widely held you know it's
hard isn't it sharon to imagine
that there is any other figure in the
world
who commands such universal
recognition but also crucially respect
even if you didn't believe in the
monarchy i think people respected the
queen
she has served this country her entire
life
she
can you imagine the things that she must
have put aside personally family
family-wise things that she would have
loved to have done to serve her country
never put it wrong
i mean a magnificent woman and
you know it's she he will go down in
history as the greatest queen country
has ever had i think she'll go down as
the greatest monarch there's ever been
you know i just think there's never
there was a young french king he was
four years old little louis when he took
over but that doesn't count uh and if
you take him out of the equation she's
the longest reigning monarch that there
has ever been in the history of this
planet and that's an amazing achievement
that we should be hugely proud of but my
question i think finally sharon for you
is we've got to now imagine for the
first time in our lives
a life without this lady at the top
without her as the figurehead for our
country and i think it's going to be a
really difficult period for britain
isn't it a hard period a sad period and
a sort of unsettling one
it's unsettling and i know the morning
will go on and on and on for our queen
it will people will never stop mourning
for her but i do have to say
that i think charles will be an amazing
king i have so much respect for him
and i i think that
he will take care of all of us well you
know what he's the longest-serving king
in waiting
uh which i think is probably great for
the country because he's had so long to
prepare for this to watch how his mother
has led the country and i i agree with
you i think charles will be a very good
king i don't think it'll be easy uh i
think it's going to be hard to follow
that act because she was so
irreplaceable in many ways charles i
think will be a good king
he will be a good king he can't follow
he can't fill her shoes but he will do
it his way yeah and he will i i have
full confidence i adore him i respect
him and he will do great things for this
country sharon it's great to talk to you
on this incredibly sad day for the
country thank you for joining me
bless you darling